hi caitlin hi evan
aren't you glad do i have a surprise
flopper no i don't
know you've gotten me too many times
only those of you guys who are watching
the youtube video now we can get the
pure panic on
caitlyn's face when i reach behind her
chair to pretend like there's a popper
behind
her oh my god well you've been getting
me with the poppers
all the time so people okay so if you
watched
the video that went out friday which is
our um our
i don't know if you want to pull it up i
want to pull it up right now i'm going
to pull it up now
and later it's our custom million sub
play button oh just looking at it makes
me excited
it's so it's so pretty at the beginning
of this video evan
totally got me with these little party
popper things
but what people who only watch the
main channel videos and haven't kept up
with the gaming stuff might not know
is that he's also pranked me several
times while live streaming
with the party poppers now i did get you
once
just like yesterday we need to keep this
room stalked
so yeah either of us at any time
yeah but if we go based on the current
like
record so far it's like five evan
poppers to one
caitlyn popper so i'm definitely going
to be the one panicking more constantly
but guys the big news in the what's new
oh here let's talk about the topic real
quick
we're gonna be talking about goals like
what makes for good goals what our
thoughts around goals what our goals for
2021
are all sorts of things around goals i
think it's going to be very interesting
podcast but first but first we just need
to take a moment to celebrate
one million youtube subscribers
i know that we don't have our official
youtube one but like dang guys
pretty hard competition i mean it'll you
know it'll still be cool
but like this is the one getting the
primo primo
also i think this might be the first
time that anyone is seeing the slight
modification that we did
where we talked about it in the after
show we actually put a little um
mirrored gold acrylic insert in there to
kind of like really
streamline that that golden look well it
was because there is like some
bubbles in the resin that clear layer of
resin so you can see some of the bubbles
through or you can when you're looking
at the um
the gold backing that we put on there
sorry it's like like looking at myself
in the reflection on the button
when we put the gold backing on there
there was a layer of clear resin between
the front of the button and the backing
and there are a few
bubbles and stuff in there so this
didn't make it into the video because we
ordered it
after we finished the project so just
got in just now yeah
um but yeah we got like a little plate
that's just the size of the play button
that fits perfectly and so there's
no bubbles it's beautiful it's
so nice are you going to keep it in your
laptop i also even did like i added some
gold
um tape on the floor tape
that looks that looks great too looks
nice this is
i know that we say this about like
everything we just made
but this is the prettiest thing we've
ever made y'all
that was really pretty until like next
week we made something else but like i
really do think that like
this is going to hold a special place in
my heart for free it's meaningful
it's very good it's beautiful and
beautiful yeah um
also huge news for five five five five
years i didn't do it the second time
it's because i was looking at you
um huge news we also passed 100k
subscribers on our gaming channel
big milestones all around it's very
exciting i did some sound effects on
here
i mean we are talking about the gaming
channel so like throw them all in might
as well
throw in some visual ones who are you
thank you guys
thank you guys we really appreciate it
thank you everybody
no we do though it's i know it seems
silly
because like we're we're celebrating a
million on the main channel and 100
might seem like a smaller or lesser
milestone but like
i remember reaching 100 on the main
channel 100 is
like very hard to get to it's a very big
deal
so we are very excited and how many
videos have we published on
our um on our gaming channel it took a
lot of videos to get to
100 000. yeah because we have more
videos on the gaming channel than on our
main channel
on our main channel we have 171. evan
perfect yeah 171
and on our gaming channel we
have 166 okay so we're all
it's not more but it's almost more it's
the gaming uncut that has
236.
yeah well oh the poor editors they have
so much to get
but you know i i think it is like a big
moment um
you know that we want to stop and
acknowledge and then think about how
cool that is too i mean
we had quit our jobs and we were
full-time content creators by the time
our main channel was 100k right yeah
well we quit it like 80k
yeah yeah but it's also very different
very good
channel we went into that like hoping to
make
that a job and by the time we quit we
had already worked with several sponsors
and we
like were treating it like a business
you know um like we had to bring in
income if we wanted to quit our day jobs
and things like that and with the gaming
it's uh very different i mean like
there's like the built-in monetization
of twitch and
um youtube um but it's
not the same like we're we're not you
know we have we've never put
sponsors on any of those videos we did
do one sponsored stream
yeah but um it's a very different game
yeah it's very different but the gaming
side of things is a different
animal how about that yeah it's a
difference when it comes to content
creation when there's
different really you know different
paths for monetization
the same things that we did for our main
channel you know
they apply in a lot of ways to the
gaming but also it's just it's just so
different
yeah um but that might be a topic for
another day that's not what we're here
to talk about
we're here to talk about goals but first
i know i noticed that a lot of you guys
had concerns
about my wrists and stuff like that in
the past couple of videos
a wrist brace on occasionally if you're
not sure what we're talking about yeah i
believe and
you know it's been hard to go in and see
a doctor in these crazy times but based
on my research
and talking to doctors that we have in
our family which we're very lucky to
have
it looks like it might be cubital tunnel
syndrome which is the cousin of carpal
tunnel
um it just affects a different nerve and
it affects your
muscles and your body in a different way
and i also think i might have
other joint things coming back from my
high school swimming days like
past injuries that still haunt me and
you know it has been affecting like how
much i can work
and it has been affecting how much i can
type and be at the computer
um so you know we've we've just
continued to try to put out as much
content as we can
while still maintaining our health and
trying to strike a
good balance and stuff but you know we
have had to take some breaks
sometimes i'll like go out and i'll do
some resin pours
and then like i'll just go lay down and
then caitlyn will like fetch me when
it's time for the next resin pour or
something like that rest when you can go
to wrestlemania because
because part of the issue is i just
haven't been able to sleep as well with
all of that yeah
um yeah yeah it's like preventing you
from sleeping some nights because it's
just
hard to get in a comfy position and but
it's great knowing that like you know
you guys
you know especially everyone here that's
made it down to the podcast
and who who like you know care enough to
listen to us just chat for an hour every
now and then
you know i i it's great knowing that you
guys have our back and
if we need to pull back when health
issues come up like
i don't have carry that big worry of
like
we're going to be abandoned yeah you
know
and all of that you know the biggest
thing is we have
calendar commitments to sponsors yeah um
and and all of that but it's great
knowing that you guys have our back and
and we appreciate that um but i think
now that takes us to the main topic
goals goals resolutions
you're just going to hold up the button
just a little bit more do you want to
just like set it here
yeah like can i just i'll just set it
here on my injured shoulder
that's probably not yeah i would like if
there's a shelf just like right here
i know that would be cool we've talked
about this on stream when we did our
designing our dream house
stream but it would be cool in a future
streaming room if we had
an option to either have the green
screen or have like a cool
backdrop with all of our treasures
and stuff all of our snails yourself all
of our snazzy stuff
like if we had like a pull down green
screen or something maybe yeah maybe in
the future
and maybe like all the cabinets behind
us they could be on rollers
cabinets like you have like shelves
shelves and stuff yeah like
display shelves display shelves if we
have display shelves it'd be cool if
they're on rollers then if we wanted to
like have something
right here that's not blurry we could
like roll it forward or something
or who knows i'm pretty sure everything
from here on out is going to be on
rollers based on like every furniture
piece we've
built recently they're great yeah i just
love rollers so much
diss desks goals of 2021
rollers everywhere rollers
all right so caitlyn yeah before we talk
about what goals that we have written
down because i have some goals written
down on my my phone
kaitlyn has some goals written down on
her face i imagine we'll have some
overlap
i think we'll have some overlap but
first i kind of want to get your
thoughts on
we haven't like i think you know one
goal
that we have in no no i shouldn't
describe my goals no
i'll describe them later no no but yeah
what's happening
what were you going to ask me about what
makes for a good
goal do i like goals do you like goals
do you like resolutions as a concept
so one of the goals that i had in 2021
written down is keep
on experimenting with new formats don't
like
just keep on doing things because that's
how it's been done
like let's like this podcast right here
i was going to use this as
an example most of the time we talk
about every little thing we're going to
talk about
to a certain degree beforehand and for
this one we're kind of just letting
things
free flow a little bit more you know we
have like a general outline but it's
more free-flowing is it i disagree with
that
i i think we have a pretty nice outline
here written on our notes to keep us on
track
comparable to our typical album
but i i do agree with that goal except
in this case i'm going to bring us back
to the outline and ask you
what do you think about goals as a
concept are like resolutions in general
i think personally
we do such a good job of goals and
resolutions and stuff on the
micro and macro scale that making yearly
goals
sometimes just doesn't make sense
because like
a year is just like uh a bunch of days
just a bunch of days it doesn't like
what does a year mean
what is like a month mean what is you
know like that time
what does a year mean but like why
define things
by a yearly scale instead of a monthly
scale or a daily scale or whatever scale
i have a rebuttal
okay but i think that like you know my
thought is
caitlyn and i talk so much about our
lives and our balance and all of that
and i think that yes i think there is
some value in
setting big overarching thing is looking
at the big picture
so you don't get stuck in the little
macro or micro goals you can
stay aware of like the the big picture
and where you're going and where you're
at and define those big goals
defining them on a yearly scale i'm not
really tied to it at all
um but i do think goals are extremely
valuable
um and then like really also trying to
build in
systems so that you do those goals like
goals are great but then action items to
follow them up
are even better yes yes breaking your
goals into action items breaking your
goals down yeah and
like this is when you see like our
experience in corporate workplaces
action items people what are the
takeaways what are the action items
yeah so it's like pick me later goals
are great
looking big is is great but yeah i
really think that you need to take it a
step further
um general ones that haven't really been
broken down
general what's like general goals like
i don't know like i mean that's an
example of like a general goal like i
want to be more happy
yeah i want to be more happy that could
be one or like
like i know one that we're that we're
going to have is
you know we want to work out more how
useful is that i think it generally is
kind of useful sometimes
general goals do work sometimes general
goals don't work
well but i think i if i'm like following
your logic correctly i think like what a
better goal might be instead of just
saying i want to work out more
it might be um like
okay i want to work out more this year
so for
the first month i'm just going to try to
work out once a week
at least like that's my minimum second
month i'm going to try to work out twice
a week
like i'm getting more concrete things or
that's a certain point but i also think
that like
you know like like also
a great follow-up to your goals is
saying like
why wasn't i doing that before what was
preventing us like because we've always
wanted to work out we know how important
working out is to your health and your
long-term
like happiness and it helps you sleep
better it has like a million bajillion
benefits
what in particular is our barrier
to that working out and i think that we
have
a two-step plan to like make working out
more viable for us very much in
particular because i think that's what
you need to do i mean
you know if you do want to accomplish a
goal and for us it's to make
goals of uh working out a positive fun
thing that we look forward to
um without much pressure more time for
it yeah
that's going to be a reoccurring thing
that we say a lot yeah
so you're kind of getting into some
specific specific goals okay yeah
one thing that i want to say just as a
slight
not full rebuttal because i'm not like
fully disagreeing with you
but i do think sometimes i think like
the benefit of something like a yearly
goal
isn't so much like i want to accomplish
this thing by the end of the year
but i i do think that like sometimes it
is
good to have a little bit of a more
general like guiding
light that sounds kind of fluffy but
like
something to help you when you're
setting your more minor goals
or your more short-term goals like oh is
this in line
with that bigger more general goal yeah
you know i also do think that like and i
think that i i kind of touched on that
too like it is good to go
look at the big picture and then go back
in and look at the big picture
every now and then because like
sometimes you might just be focused on
this one little patch
and you you are moving off in a
direction that's not aligned with your
big picture goals and i think that it is
really good to look at the big picture
but i do i do have to say
one great thing about the big picture
goal the yearly goals
is setting dates for your goals i think
is really important because if it's like
i'm gonna work out that that isn't the
most useful but like you know like i'm
gonna work out this year
that's useful or i'm gonna work out a
certain amount by the end of the month
or by the end you know per week or
something like that hopefully no one's
like i'm going to work out
in a year i'm going to work out
sometime this year starting well a year
from now december 30th you just do it
all right i got a day to spare should we
talk about some of our specific goals
you already kind of got into working out
yeah yeah i think that um i actually
want to start with work goals
yeah instead of personal goals okay
because i feel
and and this is gonna tie you know
everything together and be a little bit
of a theme but i feel like
most of our life right now is work
and in order to have personal goals we
first need to tackle the work goals
yes and i think that both of us my guess
on that list
is to reduce the amount of work but do
you have any
specifics around that because i do i do
have some specifics
um do you want to talk just well
yeah this is why we probably should have
shared our goals beforehand because i
i i you go first and i'll go next okay
so i'm gonna um do a little bit of like
a
i'm gonna go backwards a little bit
first because i do feel like
for our work we i don't know if we
like consciously stated this as a goal
but we did kind of have like a certain
mindset that like for the next big chunk
of time till we feel like
we've gotten there this is going to be
like one of our
priorities so like we are um
almost four years into content creation
now um the first year so like zero to
the one year mark i think our goal was
like let's just work as hard as we can
and see if we
this is viable so that we can quit our
jobs yeah that was kind of like
year one goal yeah the second year so
that's between like the one year and the
two year mark i think it was like
say yes to everything collabs collabs
events
like events events but also like
like sponsor relations like we would go
out of our way
to like like really
reach out and just kind of like
it's like once we knew it was viable you
know and we didn't have to worry about
just
like not drowning like we knew we could
stay afloat
it was like oh let's build on to this
we've been playing too much raft let's
build onto this raft
and like add and try all these different
opportunities and
just say yes to everything the third
year i think
was um expanding expanding into gaming
and podcast and podcast yeah i think
we've got about about the same time-ish
we did start about the pot about the
same time although the gaming ended up
being
a much bigger time much bigger time the
podcast was pretty chill but you're
expanding
expanding yeah expanding beyond just our
typical youtube videos the diy youtube
videos into gaming and
podcasting and streaming and all that um
i think our goal for the fourth year
which was
2020 refining i think it was
um i'm not necessarily going to say
refining i think our intention
was better work life balance
and continuing yeah i guess continuing
to refine
the content that we were putting out on
the main channel like
like experiment with um pushing a little
bit in this direction or a little bit in
that direction and kind of refining like
things like our you know how often we
wanted to stream and
um what types of experiences we wanted
to do you know like
all sorts of like things that like are
good to have in place we did a lot of
setup
yeah and refining systems yeah and like
well i'm not saying what we did i'm
saying what our goal was oh
okay our goal was to kind of like
really refine and like play with the
direction
of our specific content and also have a
better work life balance
i would say that we um successfully
uh refined and expanded our content and
somewhat successfully in illegal in
little steps
we slightly made the workload and burst
in fits and burst we made the work life
balance better i would say it is better
it was better in 2020
than it was in the previous years yeah
yeah
it's still not there like yeah there
were periods where it wasn't better but
there were some periods where
it was better yeah which is better yeah
it's better instead of
being constantly better yeah it was
better
i'm trying to like acknowledge our wins
yeah so i think
with that background yeah i feel like
for i'll just speak for me but i i
my guess is that you'll generally align
i think like
our work goal this year is to really
focus in more
on that work life balance
and um that applies to
twitch and youtube and the podcast and
all of social media
and um just continue to like
find that right balance for us and
you know figuring that out isn't
something
i mean i guess you can like make changes
really quickly but because we
do things like schedule our videos out
super far in advance with sponsors
we can't just like break contracts
willy-nilly because we want to
do less videos yeah so you know we can
only really affect like six months
at a time and uh if we didn't reduce
enough then
we'll have to wait six months before we
can try reducing again
yeah um but i do think that that is a
goal especially for like the youtube
side of things because um
i mean twitch twitching the gaming does
take a decent amount of time too like i
think more than we
realized yeah yeah but um yeah
i think that's like a big part of it and
i think for me
there's also like more specific to
twitch i think
this is i don't know maybe kind of silly
to say
but uh i want to keep twitch
feeling really fun because we started it
as just like a side
thing that was super fun we've continued
it as a side
thing that's super fun even though it
grew a lot in 2020
and i think just like wanting to hold on
to that
as yeah wanting to protect that and not
over schedule it
um even though i think the scheduling is
good on our main channel because that's
how we work with sponsors yeah um and
i'm not saying we'll never have anything
sponsored on the gaming side of things
because we might but i think like
just letting it still be fun and
flexible i think is like
a goal of mine um
and then i also think for our second
channel which we've been doing a little
bit more with in 2020
i think my goal is to like have room to
experiment a little bit so that kind of
overlaps with streaming because
um all of our recent second channel
content has been like
garage streams or workshop streams or
miscellaneous non-gaming streams
yeah it's like continuing to experiment
with
that and just kind of have the room to
try stuff out
and keep it stress-free like if
something doesn't work it's okay
it's the second channel it's okay like
we don't have like a sponsor minimum
view count we have to reach and
people's expectations are just different
on a second channel because it's kind of
for more experimental stuff yeah
and so i think those are some of my like
goals work wise
yeah i think that the we we lined up
pretty pretty spot we wrote down similar
or different things
i kind of concised it yeah i
use long word when short word work um
i said like new formats new shows new
ideas
like on the work side of things like i
want to keep on like
with our main channel even like continue
to like
you know like we've done in in in past
years like
i feel like all of the experimenting
we've done have
pushed us towards videos that we enjoy
more that
that find good response from our
audience because we are really enjoying
it and
and just all sorts of good stuff has
come from experimenting and
sometimes there have been duds or slower
periods or what have you but
just this again always questioning like
are we doing this just because it's
what we've done or are there better ways
so continue to experiment and also like
i agree with that
like with the like new shows it was it's
kind of like
i'm not gonna like put in a like thought
on like you know
let's do another like do more series
like it was my goal last year but like
you know
like uh just like how in 2020
we started doing graz streams and
um we uh started putting them on our
second channel
you know keep on experimenting with you
know
how like what types of games we play on
the gaming and what type of garage
streams we do in the garage and all of
that just like
think about grand ideas that excite us
or
tiny little ideas that seem super casual
like
like the christmas stream like the
christmas dream i just loved the
christmas stream
that was so nice yeah and like like i
say
shows cause like that's kind of how my
brain thinks of it even though it's not
like a tv show or anything like that
it's not going to be starting a new
channel
but like the the christmas stream was a
completely different format
not like anything we've ever done yeah
what i mean so it's like even if we did
like live streams of
cooking what if we do a live stream of
taking down the christmas tree because
it's still up
we can still make hot chocolate it can
still be a nice moment it can still be a
nice moment as we like
stuff it into black bags
oh no yeah but like just keep on
thinking of new things and like my
thought around
how to reduce our work is my
my thought is continue streamlining and
eliminating all but the most
necessary work i think that we we went
through a period a while ago where we
like
stop posting to instructables stop
posting to other places
you know we reduced and minimized and i
think that
we we really at some point soon have to
take a harsh look
yeah at how we spend our time do another
round of a little do another round of
eliminating tasks
even though like they might be things
that we like i know they might be things
that are great for the community
they might be things that that you know
are are good things now because like you
know
like uh we've been watching the bachelor
and um and the bachelorette and like you
know as they get
closer and closer to the end at the
beginning it's easier for them to say
goodbye to certain things because it's
like
nothing is that precious yet but as it
gets later in the season it's harder for
people to say goodbye to people because
they have more of a connection
and i think that at this point in our
lives we
have opened our arms wide to
all sorts of content all sorts of things
that
we do on the internet all sorts of
content types
and we have gobbled it all up and then
right not this not this not this it's
like
tick tock we tried for a while and we're
like oh this is fun and then we
said no not we forget it for months at a
time oh you kind of forgot that or
like you know we we used to write full
articles on our on our
um blog and on websites and full
tutorials and we're like you know what
that cost benefit really isn't there for
the time in
verse benefit out and all these things
and i feel like we've
shed a lot of those easier things
and i think that like you know it might
be time for us to look at like
where we put our time and start cutting
things that
are more precious to us in one way or
another because
that's where we're at in life we have so
much good
things and we want to hold on to all of
it
and we've shed all of the easy things
yeah
yeah that was my big thought that is
very interesting to think about because
i do think you're right i do think
there are some things that we like
continue to do them because we've always
done them
and they've made it past one round of
like what can we shed
in order to free up some time um
but it's been a while since we did a
round of shedding and we have done
things like um
like we planned for the video schedule
this year on the main channel
to be like every other week
is our hope you know and that
makes a lot of space but it's giving up
a lot of
you know a lot of everything yeah it's
very hard um uh
to cut down the video so yeah
and we took a we took a uh one podcast
break
you know and that was like it feels like
it's been forever it feels like it's
been forever
yeah you know and we we you know we we
need
more time in our life um
and that kind of is my transition into
life goals
life goals because we have been so busy
with work and we have prioritized it and
we knew that that's how it was going to
be we knew that we wanted to front load
everything
that was us opening our arms to
everything and like taking it all in
and then figuring out what we liked you
know because the best
time to start things online is
yesterday the second best is today you
know and
you know like with the gaming channel
i'm so glad we started that so long ago
i'm so glad we started streaming
so long ago um and that was us in the
opening up phase and now
we need to like you know close off stop
working
seven days a week all day yeah um
and and i know that you guys have said
yes that is good you should do that um
but it's also hard because we have found
all these things that we love
or are beneficial to us in some way or
you know it's like
like everything that we do the cost
benefit reward
makes sense you know to do it to do it i
mean i think that in
20 uh 20
20 20 youtube sent us like how many
comments you responded to and it was
like
it was a lot i don't fully understand it
i don't understand
50 000 comments like i don't i'm like
are you counting a
a thumbs up like as a comment i don't
know it was like
a lot of comments and then you know it's
like also like
responding to tons of emails to like
potential business partners and
just being polite to everybody you know
it's like we are
going to ignore more emails you know
it's like we we
that's who we are that's genuinely like
who we are and we like to
like be nice and you know and like
respond to bajillion comments and all of
that
but like i think that this is gonna be
like a
tough year for us you know because
everything in our life does make sense
and it is great and we enjoy
it in some way we've already it's
already made it through so many rounds
of cutting and
we still need to cut more and i think
that's the really tough thing
right now um and then once we have cut
some
stuff from our life i think the main
goal for me is to like
find out what we want to fill it with
because i think the main
thing the the main trap we have fallen
into is we knew that we were going to be
giving up a lot for a long period of
time because we
were running a startup and then we
decided we were going to start another
startup with the gaming and streaming
and we did another startup with the
podcast i mean it's a tiny
startup you know but like starting
companies starting businesses takes a
lot of time and a lot of work
that's reasonable and that makes sense
um but i feel like things are moving
along nicely now i mean
yeah look at this beautiful award
that some amazing beautiful people made
for us
ourselves ourselves
yeah no i i do i do definitely feel like
much more i'm trying to look for the
right word like
content and comfortable with our current
offerings and current like the reach of
what we do across multiple genres i'm
not like
oh i'm really itching to start this
other channel
you know what i mean yeah and that's how
it's been for us for a long time even
thinking about cooking and stuff
yeah we experimented with that we know
what that's like you know we
like and i will say we did put on our
goals list
that we want to experiment more but
experimenting within
like the stuff we've already set up yeah
not like
starting a whole new like okay guys
we're beauty youtubers now
we're tech youtubers we're tech
youtubers now caitlin is starting a
beauty channel and i'm starting a tech
channel
i thought you were starting the beauty
channel oh yeah nice
on the tech channel yeah
yeah but it's like i am very content and
happy with
like the stuff we do that makes up our
week like i love switching back and
forth between like doing projects and
like live streaming and this and it's so
nice by the time we get to our next live
stream we were like yay live stream time
yeah like in breaks between projects
we're like oh it's been a while since we
were in the garage you know because
we've been streaming and doing emails
and other stuff
so many emails oh my god
oh also we're like inbox zero people
like we strive
for inbox zero at all times like we
can't just ignore stuff like
i mean even if we are archiving it even
if we're archiving it that's still like
we need to make a decision yeah if we're
gonna ignore it yeah we do have some
filters set up and stuff
you know for like for certain things but
like
yeah we have a hard time just like
letting it go
up to like thousands and thousands of
unread emails
that's stress right there but anyways um
yeah i i don't feel that itch to like
keep expanding so i think
that is good but it i do acknowledge
that it is gonna
still be a struggle to like cut back on
the things that we're currently doing
yeah and i think that that is it's kind
of silly
in some ways to say like okay my goal is
to
free up time and see what i need to fill
it with see what i want to fill it up
with
but that just makes sense to to me
because
like i guess where i was going with all
of this is because um
you know when we started i feel like i'm
deja vu
because i did say the sentence before
then i got distracted but like when we
started
this company we knew that it was going
to be a startup moment for a period of
time
and we were like okay we're going to
move everything to the side and that has
been normalized
to us over the course of almost four
years over the course of almost four
years and like when caitlin started
getting back into reading a little bit
it was weird for you
and you had a hard time with it and then
it was good
you know but like we we kind of need to
like rediscover
in the new life situation that we're in
because we are in a weird life situation
we
enjoy our work so much but at the same
time if we just keep on going with that
default
of just do the work that you love
um you know we we are closing ourselves
off from potential other things we might
want to do
so we first need to make the time and
then figure out what we want to fill it
with
and who knows it may need to lead to
more content or like
that's the hard thing is like our
default would be to fill it with more
work
like we finally have time do you wanna
like film you cutting my hair and see if
that's a fun video yeah let's do it
let's do it and that probably is what
we're gonna do
but like so i think that's the hard
thing is we have all these things we've
been wanting to do but we've been
putting off and they're like somewhat
work related
but like you know i really do seriously
want to like
cut whatever we can and then see what we
fill it with and if it is more work
then we we keep on like you know cutting
it until we have like a little bit of
personal time
because if we're if we cut something
that isn't as like
the the cost benefit is so there if we
cut something
and we fill it with something where the
cost benefit is even better
and it's work that's okay then we cut
more things
yeah until we just keep raising the bar
of like keep on raising the bar
yeah yeah that's true you know i think i
think that that
that that's fine with me in terms of
like uh an outcome
you know like if we cut and fill it with
more work that's even better
so it is your is your main um personal
goal like free up time so that we can
figure out what to fill it with
my other personal goal is like another
just big one but like
it's kind of related to it's kind of
related to work but it's kind of related
to home this is a shared one
make progress on our next home yep
that's on my list too
because honestly guys we waste
time um
due to our small home we i think it's
worth
investing the money and time
to upgrade our life and our business
because we are outgrowing because we are
outgrowing it we really need to expand
into much more room because so much of
like at the end of the project it's like
clean up
shuffle everything around again where do
we put all this new stuff
and in our personal constant shuffling
in our personal life
caitlyn doesn't like clutter she doesn't
like inefficiency
she doesn't like stuff just being around
the amount of
stuff we have to deal with leads to
stress
and the amount of juggling we need to do
in our
in our work life takes up time
that takes away from our work and our
personal life and it just like
is inefficient but at the same time to
do a new home
right how we want to do it will take a
lot of time
so it's like it's like a catch 22
in some ways it's like we need time to
get find our new home and
make that the solution that we need to
get time
to free up time you know it's like yeah
yeah that's a big thing us getting a new
house
i my goal this is my like
um uh my goal that has like a little bit
less pressure on it is to like
at least start looking
at places and even just to start looking
that's a lot of work we need to define
the location
well that's the right thing we could be
anywhere
like we in some ways we have so much
more flexibility because
you know we work from home so we can
work anywhere but in other ways
we have a lot of weird requirements if
we're going to be moving to another
house we need a place
where we can that either has or we can
build a much bigger workshop
that means like we can't be in a typical
neighborhood we can't be in like a
downtown
area like we're gonna have to
be where there's not hoa requirements
and
um yeah you know and i know that that is
just just work i mean we know we can do
it
but it's also in in our minds to a
certain degree
the ramping up of that makes a lot more
sense to do all at once instead of in
little fits and bursts
because for the ramp up i feel like you
can make progress and slide backwards
and make progress and slide backwards
once you even if we had like
three days to just like make it up that
hill yeah to the lower
slope that we can just roll along i feel
like that'd be great too
but like it's it's tough seems
melodramatic but like
we really haven't had large chunks of
time in a while
yeah unless we like really like make it
happen for something like
christmas or holidays or something like
that takes a lot of work it takes a lot
of work
like we're we're usually very stressed
out
right before and right after holiday
breaks if you look at our like we have a
workout
tracking calendar and like december's
just dark
we didn't work out at all in december we
only worked out four times in november
and we've been doing great like a couple
times a week for the previous two months
yeah but like you know like i think that
the the calendar does reflect like
how much we have to extra hustle to free
up time
yeah and i guess we could just do that
we're like okay we're gonna extra hustle
for two weeks
and then we're gonna have three days i
just i it just doesn't sound appealing
it's it's like i know maybe that makes
sense to like
make times that we can do something like
devote a big chunk of time to like
figuring out what we you know like where
we might want our next house to be and
stuff like that
but it's like it's less stressful to me
on a day-to-day week-to-week basis
to just keep working at our current pace
and not have time for that stuff than it
is to like
really hustle so that we can take a
couple days off yeah
yeah you know but it's not really off
but yeah well it's not off i mean yeah
yeah
it could take a couple days to where we
don't do any work stuff yeah on those
days
um so like it's it's we only do that for
things that are worth it
you know so it's normally like hanging
out with family yeah you know
yeah because that's worth it but um it
makes it harder when it's like this
nebulous thing that doesn't have a
specific timeline and there's not like a
specific date we have to move
by it's just we're in full control of
everything yeah
we can delay as much as we want exactly
but no i do think um i want to like make
progress on it
cool any other goals that you have those
are the main things
um yeah i wrote down well this is
it's all kind of stuff we talked about
but i wrote down make more room for
family time
because but that kind of ties in to just
like make more room in general but
i would like to see family more
and hopefully i mean a lot of the past
year
um like part of the reason we were
mostly by ourselves
was because of covey and hopefully
things will get better this year
yeah you know um so yeah make more room
for family time
um work out and keep working out fun
because we've been working out while
watching the bachelor and that's a blast
honestly like the way that we will make
working out
stick is by like working out well you
want to treat yourself
yeah making it treat yourself time and
then
new house question mark question mark
question mark
that's that's what i wrote that's like
the big one i think that's the big
change the other things are just like a
continuation of stuff we were already
trying to do yeah i feel like we're on
the right track
on on so many like paths
you know um in terms of like platform
specific
goals like trying to think youtube i
feel like
we understand youtube for our youtube
channels i don't
know if there's really anything i'd
change about our youtube strategy
i mean i think you're the goals we've
already listed because we've already
shopped apply
like yeah to all of the different
channels in general and
i don't think it's any different than
i'm not sure i'm not sure what you want
to talk about that we haven't already
covered because we already talked about
goals for youtube and twitch and second
channel and content and all that stuff
honestly like one thing i might want to
maybe do
specific is maybe not post as much on
social on socials
yeah well that might fall into the like
what can we cut can we cut
some stuff from because maybe we don't
need to be posting five times a week
yeah on all the platforms i don't know
yeah and i guess that's not something
that we can like
go through ourselves and like look at
like put put spread everything out on
the operating table and see what we can
cut
you know i mean it sounds brutal it
sounds brutal it does sound painful
you know yeah especially with that
analogy
yeah sounds very gory
spreading it out on the operating table
i mean
that's kind of how i think of it you
know we've built this beautiful machine
and we're going to be
i don't know taking out its eyeballs not
as eyeballs
taken out it's it's what's what's its uh
thing that
that that doesn't do anything
appendicitis appendicitis
although actually we've already taken
out we've already taken out its appendix
honestly
yeah that's true it's time to lose a
limb it's gonna have to sacrifice its
left arm
our least favorite limb yeah what's your
least favorite limb
yeah yeah that's kind of brutal too
no i mean that's i i don't think we'll
lose a limb it's um
just shaving down the limb yeah yeah
i think one thing that's that's kind of
interesting around goals that's that's
really weird for us
is if we were working traditional jobs
we wouldn't be able to
have all these work goals as much i mean
they might be different maybe like you
move jobs or you
negotiate a raise or all of that i think
it's just weird that like we're we can
say like
like you can't just like most people
can't just go to the boston and say
hey boss i think i'm just gonna not do
this as much yeah that's true
that's true it is i think it's weird it
puts more of a burden on us
but it also opens up us for that
possibility
you know because we need to make
ourselves
we need to make those decisions yeah you
know which does put a burden on us but
it also
allows us to make those decisions but
it's it's a
yeah i mean i'll i'll say it's like the
word burden is very like light
in this burden isn't the right word it's
it's responsible responsibility yeah
yeah that's i think that's a better way
it puts the
like i'll say burden of responsibility
it's like
yeah like burden wasn't the right word
because i'd say it's pretty
pretty light in the grand scheme of
things yeah yeah yeah but like
yeah but it is interesting normally if
you think of like life goals and work
goals you have
you just don't you may not have as much
control over your work goals unless it's
of a set few things like i'm going to
change jobs or i'm going to try for that
promotion coming up
yeah it's not like so much in that like
i just don't want to do this anymore so
i'm not going to do it and instead i'm
going to do this
yeah i think it's interesting though
it's like you know i've talked to
some some makers about like
choosing what project to do and like you
know i know that some people
do better if they're like okay take this
material and make something that
accomplishes this goal with it
that's a lot easier to say like okay i'm
just going to do the best i can and make
it really cool and extra special and i'm
just going to go you can just go on that
and for for us it's like we can
to a certain degree we can do anything
with any material
and you know everything like that and it
takes a lot more
time for us to like work through all
those options and it's
it's more difficult to just go and i
think that it's a similar thing when it
turns
when it comes to goals and stuff like
that if you have limited choices you can
just like kind of decide which choice
but when you have
almost you know a lot more choices it's
kind of like
when you are shopping at the grocery
store people have like
fatigue choice fatigue like the jam like
the jam
people have figured out number of jams
is i forget what it is
15 or something like that like it's much
lower oh okay
six jams some number of jams now if you
have only have two jams people don't
like that
if you have like eight jams that's great
but when you have like
200 jams no one wants 200 jams
and sometimes it feels like we have 200
jams
yeah i'm just gonna i'm just gonna move
on no no no
i'm just gonna like i'm gonna
acknowledge everything
you said as like things are you know
within the bubble of our life those are
some things that we struggle with but i
think especially considering
like all of the struggles that so
many people have faced especially like
right now and this year
i just want to make sure everyone knows
like like
you know we're like
we don't actually think that we like
have it rough or anything like that like
it's by far the opposite we feel super
lucky
and like we think that every day too
yeah we think it we think it every day
and when i think especially like with
comparing
or with talking about like the struggles
of the work part of it
like there's so many more difficult
struggles
that people are having work-wise right
now like a lot of people don't have jobs
or a lot of people have jobs where they
like
are on the front line out there working
and so
like you know we're we just don't want
it to be misconstrued that we think this
is
like any work-related or life-related
struggles that yeah
we talk about or anything like related
to that like we fully acknowledge and
feel very lucky that we are in a very
fortunate situation
yeah i think it's tough because it's you
know it's like we want to
strike all these different balances of
being honest
yet considerate and and everything like
that
i think that also we don't want to
complain too much to you guys i think
it's like
it's like you know we even i i even i'm
just gonna kind of go down a
tangent on that like i even like at one
point
had the thought to do a podcast around
hi
that whole topic and how
how i think that like within the content
creator industry it is kind of like
to a certain degree it's it's hard for
people
to talk about any of their struggles
because
we are all all content creators who have
had this turned into their full-time job
so so so lucky
super lucky and i think that everyone
who is in it
acknowledges that but i also think that
like i sometimes think at certain times
that like because of that thought
because of that
instinct you know we are
and i think that everyone presents the
ideal version of their life
is sitting on there we hopped up and
she's sitting on the mic
why are like my headphones now you're
gonna have to stay crouched
i might be able to lift it but she's
like laying on it too but
she's laying on it fully okay you know
it's just it's just gonna be stretched
out
here i'll just pull it through there you
go
there you go she didn't mind she didn't
put some slack on the other side of her
hi
sweet girl thanks for joining me yeah
yeah but i think that that it is
tough to like you know there is
a balance between like being real yeah
being real but not being overly
complaining yeah
yeah it's always a balancing act you
know you have to
yeah walk that line and overall even
when we are
like complaining about something and i'm
putting that in quotes cause like
i mean i think talking about like
challenges isn't necessarily the same as
complaining yeah um but even when we are
like talking about challenges
and stuff like it's all with us
like ah words are hard but like
we're we're always grateful for
the job that we have jube is rubbing her
head on the mic and it's jiggling
we're always like grateful for the job
that we have and like even when we're
talking about challenges
like even with that we don't have like
regrets about what we're doing
or like dislike for what we're doing
it's just like
you know no matter what you do there's
going to be certain types of challenges
yeah um yeah i mean i'd still much
rather
be doing this than any of our other past
jobs you know what i mean yeah i i
definitely
and we could we already did like talked
about our past jobs and stuff but one
thing
i maybe didn't mention is like looking
into the future doing that job
i got kind of anxious about like that
because i wasn't fully sure if i
wanted to be on that path long term and
when i
do think about this job even with the
200 jams on the wall
i know that i do want to be doing this
forever you know and and that's that's a
really good feeling to have
yeah and to like know deep down that
like
this is such the right fit for the two
of us it's our calling
like in some ways like caitlyn and i
talk about like all the time how
you know we both did blogs and shared
our art and
like you know yeah we used to share
stuff online before people were sharing
stuff online
yeah i mean you know this is exactly
what we want to do and not
like my dream from when i was a little
kid was to have a workshop
decked out so that i could make anything
i wanted you know
and that is our job now so we're so
lucky and grateful i think we kind of
went on a big side tangent
we did there that's okay that's okay
um any more thoughts on goals i think
we've covered it pretty well
shall we move on to thing of the week
yeah time for
wait i have a sound effect for that
time for thing of the week
am i going to remember to do the outro
music we'll see you know we'll see we'll
we'll look at the footage and see if
there's a good place to add the intro
music if not it just won't be there
if you're wondering why it wasn't there
if it's not there and you're wondering
here's your answer
we forgot my thing of the week has to do
with
um my wrist problems that i'm having
this
is a vertical mouse you hold it
kind of like you're shaking someone's
hand kind of like this i'm
also holding it as opposed to this yeah
your hand doesn't go on top of it it's
like at a 45 degree
45 degree angle like so pretty like
you're reaching out to shake someone's
hand but instead you're grabbing
a computer mouse uh it just prevents the
amount of strain on your wrist from
turning it
over and it reduces the amount of
curling of your hand that you have to do
it does take a little bit of adjusting
in terms of like getting used to it
getting accurate with it figuring out
how to move with it
but i mean i've played all of raft with
this mouse oh yeah
yeah and you know all three episodes all
three episodes
i borrowed that one i have two two of
them now that's pretty impressive for
like doing a game i think that's a
pretty good test of it yeah pretty good
now it's not a first person shooter
but still you know it's it's more
functional and everything like that but
my entire life i've been using a normal
mouse
and i switched to a vertical mouse
pretty fast
um so you've been doing it for like a
couple weeks now right
a couple weeks i think um yeah and uh i
like it
and i'm also experimenting with a split
uh mechanical keyboard um that can you
know
that's angled and has its own ergonomic
things going for it
okay i gotta ask about mechanical
keyboards because it was split and i
went to try it out
and i went to type the letter b and i
reached with my right hand
to type the letter b yeah how many of
you guys use b with your right
you do the b left yeah type some type of
word with the letter b
right now and tell me if you use your
right hand for the b
or your left hand for the b because on
the split keyboard it's on the left
and every time i try to use your
keyboard i'm
just tapping blank plastic with my
my right index finger trying to touch
that b
i think in a week you'd reacclimate no
no problem i probably would i am
considering it like
like doing it preemptively because we
are on the computer a lot and i
you know my wrist and hands are fine
they don't bother me but
yeah like and even if um you know i do
resolve
like you know the the sprain and strain
i have on my hand
because of who knows what the trigger
was but if
through rest and and everything it
recovers fine
i'm still glad that i moved to more
ergonomic solutions
just because it's it's more ergonomic
it's more
it's more natural it just punched his
own mic
into his face for anyone who's listening
and not watching the video yeah
so so this is my pick uh you know the
the the
in terms of the keyboard the jury is
still out to a certain degree but i
think
yes but i think for the mouse i really
like
this change and i think it's good we'll
have a link to the mouse um it's a
logitech i think
yeah yeah we'll have a link to the
specific one in the description
yeah as always um so my thing of the
week
um is something i got for christmas and
it is
a new chai tea
and it is a blue lotus masala chai
blue lotus is like the brand um and like
i'm always on the hunt
for really really good chai tea and i
think the issue i've
had with past chai is like it's just not
strong enough it's just not spicy enough
because i like to add a lot of milk to
it
to make it like super rich and creamy
and then with most of them by the time
you add the milk it just waters it down
so much
yeah and you just even if you do
multiple tea bags brewed into a
small thing of water and then you add
your milk it's just not strong enough
well caitlin has forever been chasing
there's this local um
restaurant that has the best masala chai
and caitlin has been chasing that taste
for years for years yes um
and so i was curious about this because
it got really good
ratings and it's not like a tea bag that
you steep
and then toss it is a ground
powder of all the spices and there's no
there's no
added sweeteners there's no like milk
powder
it's just like the spices but ground up
fine enough that they dissolve
so you heat up some water you do a scoop
and you like dissolve it and then you um
add like your honey or whatever
sweetener
and your milk it is so freaking good
it's so good it's the closest i've found
to like
legit legit masala chai it's
so good i i enjoy it a lot it's really
tasty
and it's nice because you can just like
if you want it spicier
you just dissolve a little bit more and
it is it does have it does reach the
upper limit
yeah it does have spice like there's
like like a
black pepper in there and like you know
some people might not like that because
it is
just spiced but i really really like it
it's so freaking good so anyways we'll
link it yeah yeah and i think that's
that's that's the episode wow that time
went by really fast
it always does it always does um i hope
you guys enjoyed today's episode
as always we do keep an eye on all of
those reviews rolling in
and i see that you guys are starting to
like like
get get on board with the prank the
prank being we
um want people to we want the podcast to
get high enough up in the ranks yeah
that people click on it thinking like oh
this must this must be good
also some of the reviews like are like
ambiguously vague
the thing is vague in a positive way
and like this podcast changed my life i
recommend that everyone listen to it
people find us on podcast apps and they
they aren't familiar with our channel
none of it's going to make sense it's
going to be a super pointless podcast
that's going to like when when the first
like zero star review shows up
we'll know that the prank has worked and
all of a sudden
get a zero star review that's how we
know we've reached it
none of you guys can give us a zero star
review because then the prank
has failed like i want i want i want
someone to be very confused
i want to play like i was waiting for
this to change my life
all right guys um i hope you're having a
great day and look forward to seeing you
in the next thing
bye oh
that was really fun yeah
we're still we're still here but